at a community center in southeast
London they're getting back into
training what makes this football club
different is it's the only one in the
country specifically for Muslim women
Sisterhood FC only started in 2018 but
it's clear how much it means to its
members I came across them through
Instagram
Sisterhood FC and I saw that there were
lots of hijabis lots of girls who looked
like me and I thought let me let me give
it a shot and I went to their training
session and it was so much fun and all
the girls were so welcoming and lovely
and I never went back to anything else
initially the club struggled with
funding but recently for the first time
it's played five aside and seven aside
in the ladies Super League
we were really determined to say like
well yeah this is what we look like but
we could still play war and we can still
get pretty far in the league and we came
forth and it was for our first kind of
League I think we're really happy about
that to be fair regardless of results
it's already proving invaluable for
young women from across the capital
recently some have got together to watch
World Cup matches it's nice to see that
the World Cup is for everyone and it's
like it can be represented in countries
outside of Europe and in like Muslim
countries so it's it's nice to see that
and
um I was I was supporting Iran when they
were playing with they're out with the
league now sort of like I've lost
interest a little bit well we might be a
long way from the World Cup stadiums in
Qatar but for these players what matters
most is simply enjoying the sport and
being able to be themselves
and as it attracts new players the hope
is the club can offer a welcoming space
to more Muslim women for years to come
Nadine barber Al Jazeera rotherhine in
London